let's talk about spoilers everyone draws
the line differently on how much they
want to see of a game before they play
it but for me personally it's here two
weeks before release that things always
kind of start to get awkward you know
marketing starts to show too much early
copies of the game sometimes get into
circulation
and it's now more than any other point
that i think you have to be careful if
you want to preserve some of your first
experience
so this video does contain new
information and new areas but the
footage i'm going to share with you is
pretty tame i'm only going to inform you
of new game mechanics and i'm mostly
just going to talk about how the game
has changed specifically in the network
test area and since the network test
version recently i was asked to sit down
with the final build of the game and i
was told i could talk about pretty much
everything which
is an overwhelming thought as a creator
obviously i'm very privileged to have
been in this position but as you might
imagine being told this is kind of
anxiety-inducing because
you have the whole incredible game at
your fingertips but only for a short
amount of time so i wonder what would
you do the logical thing is just to rush
through a lot of the game you know your
time is limited but you can go
everywhere and talk about everything so
you feel like you have to experience as
much as you can or else your content
won't be as good as the competitions
therefore tons of creators and outlets
are going to be vying for your attention
with what they've found
i don't think this is necessarily wrong
i just think that you should know that
it's going to be a free-for-all right
now and a lot of unique discoveries are
going to be talked about because this is
an open world game and you can run very
far on torrent in six hours
one outlet in particular has been
talking about their time with the final
build for weeks and
i read an area spoiler from them that i
really wish i hadn't so
keeping that personal experience in mind
when i played the final build the area
that i explored the most was actually
just the network test zone i think i'd
rather just talk about this area that
we've all had a chance to see and
experience you know
so this is old footage of the network
test where i just went around looking at
the scenery and it'll be good to explain
what's changed since this version
so the first thing from the network test
that i can explain are these gargoyle
statues and this fog wall that's behind
them
these statues take something called
stone's ward keys and these keys are
essentially ferrous lockstones from dark
souls 2. they are a key that is limited
in number that gets used up every time
you use it i found a few of these keys
when i was playing through the game you
can actually choose one as a starting
gift for your character and i found a
lot of these gargoyles and gates where
they could be used and every single time
i used one i got a special weapon or a
special item so clearly they're a way
for you to get powerful gear or items or
maybe even unlock a shortcut like they
are in dark souls 2 i suppose next thing
i want to say is that the ui has been
updated for example health bars focus
bars stamina bars they all look a bit
more worn and they have a sort of golden
embellishment around their edges
here we have carle carle sells very
different things in the final build of
the game he no longer sells weapons i
believe and he no longer sold me any
spirit summons he did sell something new
called notes these are essentially like
memos from sakura
they're basically something you can read
that tells you about a secret location
or gives you a hint about something
just then i was looking at that island
which is the altar of dragon communion
in the network test you could trade
dragon heart for grails raw but in the
final build of the game you can trade a
dragon heart for one of three different
dragon spell attacks you can get dragon
more which bites you can get dragon claw
which swipes and you can also get dragon
fire which was already in the network
test somewhere else
so here is stormfoot catacombs and
this was one of the first dungeons that
i explored and it was here that i
noticed oh man yeah this is the final
build of the game because enemies were
dropping their weapons the items i was
finding were way less powerful just more
like they were tuned to a character that
was just starting out at the very start
of the game and the same goes for grove
side kevin which is just ahead here i
didn't get the flask of wondrous physic
from this boss you know maybe as
expected that's a really powerful potion
and it was present in the network test
and that's when you realize like the
network test had all of these powerful
things and this final build of the game
was much harder because you started as
you know
a normal starting character that didn't
have spells or didn't have strong
equipment and you know the game was
harder as a result a lot of people
criticized the network test for being
too easy but it was too easy for a lot
of people because we were playing with
like really powerful weapon arts and
really powerful spells and things that
had obviously been put in by the
developers to make our experience more
smooth
right here actually you see that fire
that i just knocked that soldier into i
looked at that for the longest time when
i was playing the final build because it
had three butterflies fluttering around
it and at first i thought it was just a
graphical improvement
but no they've actually added the
smoldering butterfly as a craftable
resource that you can loot from a lot of
the fires in the game and it looks
really pretty in this area i looted a
few things the item in this carriage i
believe is the flail which is the
hanging ball and chain i also looted a
greatsword which i used throughout most
of my playthrough and ended up
regretting because i'm not much of a
great sword user but
in that camp i also looted my first ash
of war
and it came with an item called a
whetstone knife which i believe
is the method by which you apply ashes
of war at grace checkpoints this knife
is a key item and i think you just get
this knife whenever you loot your first
ash of war i don't think it's something
you actually have to find there another
key item i found i found this in the
demi human cave were tailoring tools
which enables armor alterations at sites
of grace for a long time people were
wondering if you could add or remove
cloaks from certain sets of armor and i
can confirm that yes you can add or
remove cloaks for a small cost to your
armor and i assume you can change your
armor in a myriad of different ways
depending on the armor set which is very
very cool for the people who love
fashion souls
down here i actually look through this
veil this is where the network test ends
and that leads towards sort of easton
lim grave
down there is a deep forest with bears
and other really intimidating creatures
honestly going down there
and venturing into this you know beyond
where you don't have a map it's
intimidating because you get used to
having the map in the network test but
when you don't have one you're really
looking out for those obelisks that give
you a map and help to guide you where
you're going because you feel very lost
and
the world feels even larger when you're
lost which is something i noticed um
here at the post town remains i cleared
that out and it's actually very similar
to the network test in that pumpkin head
is down there and sorceress sellin is
also still there
although there's been some visual
upgrades to the cellar that she resides
in which looks nice
this roaming carriage in the network
test gave you the crucible set but in
the final build of the game it gives you
a great axe which i didn't use but i
assume is pretty powerful and a pretty
insane strength build weapon
so we're heading towards southern limb
grave now
and as i was in this area in the final
build there was like a little war going
on i think it was towards the left here
there was a war going on between some
soldiers of godric and some demi-humans
that were having like an all-out brawl
here
i let them fight each other always
helping the losing side and evening the
odds until they were all dead and this
game is just cool like drawing you
towards points of interest that are
always going on around the map i thought
that was interesting
but speaking of the map
we couldn't go here in the network test
but there's a giant land mass to the
south and
on that land mass there is a walking
island that you would have seen
in the early trailers for the game
so i figured out what these islands are
for they have to do with a mechanic in
the game called remembrance and
remembrance i believe i'm not 100
certain but i believe remembrance is a
way of duplicating boss souls which
obviously is very useful because you
know a lot of boss souls in dark souls
games are able to be transposed into
weapons and you might want more than one
of those souls to get more than one
weapon from them so those islands do
serve a purpose
so in this footage i walk away from the
dragon burnt ruins but make sure you
explore the dragon burnt ruins in the
final build it's very different if you
like the twin blade that's where you can
find the twin blade and there is another
chest there with some just incredible
loot it'll just blow you away you might
recall in the network test the dragon
burnt ruins gave you the crimson
talisman which increases the amount of
health you would have had on your
character talismans function like rings
did in dark souls and rings in elden
ring are more like items that you use
with a story significance so that's why
they're called talismans in this game
that's what miyazaki said anyway
but talismans in this game seem to be
really interesting i found a lot of
talismans that related to the type of
weapon i was using for example there was
a twin blade talisman that increases the
amount of damage done by the final
attack in your twin blade flurry
there was a curved sword talisman which
increases the amount of guard counter
damage you do with your curved swords
and there was an axe talisman that
increases the amount of damage done by
charge attacks with your axe so the
talismans that you find are actually
very specific in a lot of cases to the
type of build that you're going for
oh and another thing i found interesting
in the final build was the scarcity of
smithing stone shards
in the network test on this plateau that
we're on right now
back there there was a statue that gave
you six of them if you broke it right in
front of me there used to be one here as
loot and all of the giants in this area
used to drop one smithing stone shard
every time you killed one
in the final build the giants didn't
drop a shard every time that statue back
there only gave me three and the
smoldering giant up here for example in
the network test he gives you three but
in the final build he gave me none the
only place i found a lot of smithing
stone shards were the caves where there
was lots of miners and i guess that
makes a lot of sense so you're
definitely going to be incentivized to
seek out caverns and miners and loot the
shards from that place in order to
upgrade your weapon so yeah a lot of the
stuff that i'm describing does make the
game harder for sure
right up here for example this evergel
it doesn't contain the bloodhound
anymore instead
it contains a crucible knight boss and
i couldn't beat this guy i didn't try
very many times admittedly but he
basically one shot me and was very
difficult to defeat which just makes me
so excited to play the final game and
beat my head against a wall until the
wall breaks until i can beat bosses that
give me trouble because that's
how i kind of play i get pretty stubborn
about beating a boss and
i couldn't do that in this final build i
couldn't set my mind to defeating
something and spend hours on it because
you know i would miss out on so much
more of the game
the scavenger shack is something you
should explore in the final build by the
way don't just assume it's empty it's
not empty at all in the final build
and you'll notice i haven't talked about
spirit summons yet spirit summons were
harder to find in the final build at
least in my experience the summoning
bell the item you get to summon them is
found in the early game so you don't
have to worry about that but the summons
themselves the items i only found i
think two in the final build i could be
wrong but honestly the one that i found
was so powerful it was called soldiers
of godric and it summoned two knights
one of them was a melee fighter and the
other one wielded a crossbow and stood
in the back and
i mean they were still really powerful i
don't think the final build has changed
the power level of spirit summons much
at all
but then the spirit summons that you
summon do use fp so the strength of the
summon is dependent on how much fp it
consumes so this is an easy way for from
software to tweak the power of spirit
summons in the future if some are used
too often you know i'm sure they'll have
data on that there are some spirit
summons i found that used so much fp to
summon that i couldn't summon them with
my fp bar i had to upgrade my mind stat
in order to even use them the soldiers
of godric summons were found in this
jellyfish graveyard by the way oh
another thing that happened that i
forgot to mention was that i was riding
my mount on the beach and all of a
sudden it started to rain down with
these golden leaves from the earth tree
and i noticed that my character actually
got a buff at this moment i thought that
was a really cool dynamic sort of
weather effect i don't know what the
buff did
but the thought that you can just
randomly get a buff as an environmental
effect is pretty cool and i can imagine
that happening and you being like yeah
i'm gonna fight the boss that's nearby
with this buff active that will give me
an advantage oh and if you go north past
stormville you'll actually discover a
shortcut hidden in the bushes that cuts
through the cliffside and turns into a
cave and then you're on the edge of the
cliff and it takes you to an area that's
not stormvale
i was always thinking that stormvale
would sort of be like a funneling point
for progression but it seems like you
can bypass it and keep going which is
really interesting
and you know after making it to the end
of stormville castle i see why you might
want to bypass stormville castle godric
the demigod boss at the end of this
place
i thought i was pretty geared at the end
of my session but i tried him about
three times and i just walked away
because i was getting absolutely
destroyed and i thought i was doing
pretty well up until that point and
after exploring stormville for a little
while i'm not sure exactly when this
happens but eventually you get invited
to round table hold which as you
probably know by now is a hub area
and
it's amazing i don't want to spoil why i
think it's amazing
you've seen maybe one screenshot of it
but just the atmosphere and the npcs in
this hub area make it
so [ __ ] enchanting and incredible i
was absolutely in love with this hub
area
from the time that i played
so i hope i'm walking the line with
spoilers on a pretty good level just
look forward to so many things there's
so many things to look forward to i
think the last thing i'm going to leave
you with is this clip this piece of
video that they gave me to show off
there's a painting here and when you
touch it a little fog dissipates and
something in your world has changed
guess what it is on the painting there's
a visual it shows a part of limgrave and
if you go to where this painting depicts
a short event will happen and
i love this mechanic because it really
rewards players that are paying
attention to the world around them and
the map and
if you don't know where a place is it
might feel a bit like a treasure hunt
and trying to
find it from contextual clues i think
this is such such a cool thing
i know a lot of you might be wondering
where i've been for the last month or so
since my last video i haven't posted on
twitter i didn't make any videos even
though i had two lore videos planned um
i've been working on soul arts which is
the art book that i've been curating i
had to write
over 100 entries i had to work on so
many design elements of the book and
finally just the other day we launched
the digital edition to kickstarter
backers which was really exciting and in
april the final version of the book will
be sent out to everyone who pre-ordered
a copy through kickstarter or
pre-ordered through the publisher's site
i'll leave a link to the book that you
can pre-order if that's something that's
interesting to you but yeah now that i'm
done with that for the most part i can
focus on eldon ring i'm going to have
hopefully two more lore videos talking
about the network test law and also the
law that i've gleaned from the final
build and
i don't think talking about law is
really a spoiler because i don't think
learning about the fundamentals of a
story can really
spoil your game experience you know i
feel like learning about the
fundamentals will enrich your experience
when you do play elden ring so there are
a few more videos coming and that is the
goal for this channel is to enrich your
experience with the games that we love
and
i hope that i achieved that in this
video i know it's an awkward line that i
had to walk but
i think i did okay thank you so much for
watching and i'll see you next time
[Music]